so someone had a question should I
consume cruciferous vegetables with a
hypothyroid condition very good question
because cruciferous in the form of kale
broccoli brussel sprouts cabbage has the
ability to block iodine okay well we
don't want to do that but the benefit of
cruciferous is huge
it helps clean up estrogen so it's great
for estrogen dominance one of the
primary causes of hypothyroid issues it
also cleans up the liver the other cause
of many thyroid conditions were because
you actually have to convert t4 to t3 so
if there's a liver problem or a
gallbladder problem that alone can give
you a hypothyroid condition so i
recommend consuming cruciferous get the
benefit from it but just add some sea
kelp add two in the morning and get a
little capsules and you're good to go
make sure it's high quality but that'll
give you enough iodine to compensate for
any loss of iodine coming from
cruciferous vegetables and by the way
out of all the cruciferous vegetables
kale has the least iodine depleting
effects of any of the cruciferous
vegetables alright I'll talk to you
later hey tell me what you think about
this video go ahead and comment below
and give me your feedback